يبدو ان مساعي ايجاد حل سلمى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا تحول الى مجرد سراب مع تمسك كل
طرف مواقفه فشواهد تشير الى ان اقناع
الطرفين بالدخول في مفاوضات السلام باتا
بعيدا المنال اخر هذه الاشارات بالطبع
زياره المبعوث الخاص للصين الى كياف والذي
التقى خلالها الرئيس الاوكراني مبعوث
اعترف بان الازمه لا يوجد لها دواء سحري
لتنتهي هو انه يتعين على الاطراف تهيئه
الظروف للمفاوضات كيف ترى ان لا تعد طرفا
مناسبا للتوسط لانهاء الحرب
خلال زيارته لاوكرانيا يلتقي الممثل الخاص
لي هو الرئيس الاوكراني
اتفق الجانبان على ان الاتصال الهاتفي بين
الرئيس شيجن بينج والرئيس الينسكي منذ وقت
ليس ببعيد اشار الى اتجاه تنميه العلاقات
الصينيه الاوكرانيه واتفق البلدان على
انهما يجب ان يعمل معا لمواصله تقليد
الاحترام المتبادل والصدق بين الجانبين
ومواصله دفع التعاون متبادل المنفعه بين
البلدين لا يوجد دواء سحري لحل الازمه يجب
على جميع الاطراف ان تبدا من نفسها وان
تتبادل الثقه وان تهيئ الظروف لانهاء
الحرب وبدء محادثات السلام على اساس
الوثيقه وموقف الصين من الحل السياسي
للازمه الاوكرانيه
هل تنجح مبادره السلام في ايقاف الحرب في
اوكرانيا
مساعي التوسط بين موسكو وكيف تصطدم بشروط
صارمه من الجانبين
فما هي شروط كل طرف من اجل التفاوض
اوكرانيا لن نتنازل عن اي جزء من اراضينا
مقابل السلام
اي اتفاق سلام يجب ان يعتمد على احترام
سيادتنا ووحده اراضينا
روسيا يجب ايقاف امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه
لاوكرانيا يجب على كييف التعهد بعدم
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي او الناتو
يجب حمايه حقوق المواطنين الناطقين
بالروسيه في اوكرانيا
الوساطه الصينيه حقيقه ليست الوحيده فهناك
مبادره افريقيه ايضا للمساعده في ايجاد حل
للنزاع بين مصر موسكو المبادره تقود هذه
المره جنوب افريقيا التي قالت
في كل من موسكو
وتعد الدول الافريقيه من ضمن اكثر
المتضررين من النزاع ولا سيما في ارتفاع
اسعار الحبوب وسلاسل التوريد لكن ماذا عن
اصداء المبادره بالنسبه لخلفاء كييف رئيس
جنوب افريقيا سريل راما فوزا قال ان
المبادره لقيت دعما حذرا من الولايات
المتحده وعدد من العواصم الاوروبيه هذه
المبادره تاتي قبيل قمه روسيه افريقيه من
المقرر عقدها في نهايه يوليو المقبل من
جانبه اكد المتحدث باسم الكريم
في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه
كانت هناك محادثه هاتفيه بين الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ورئيس جنوب افريقيا
وكانت محادثه جوهريه وبناءه رئيس جنوب
افريقيا قال باعتبار ان افريقيا اكبر قاره
تفكر ايضا اعطاء صوتها في الجهود الدوليه
لتسويه الوضع في اوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات